okay we are now in the NFL season I
won't spend a lot of time on football I
know people don't like it when I do that
but already we have people calling in
and leaving messages about the New
England Patriots take a listen to this
hey David
the Patriots are literally the worst
team in the National Football League oh
it's weird because they're clearly not
well no I think it's because after the
first game yeah and the NFL season later
it's were the only team that we Rowan
won whereas the rest of the teams where
the Chiefs case want to know or oh and
haven't played yet what a dumb voicemail
yeah anyway yeah Super Bowl this year
the last three times that the Patriots
lost the opener they ended up winning
the Super Bowl is that true that's true
I did not know that statistic all right
great bonus show for you today a lot of
stuff to tell you about great stories
blah blah blah all that stuff people
said David no more blah blah blah but
this bonus show has no shortage of blah
david pakman.com slash membership you
can also get access to the bonus show at
patreon.com slash david pakman show